I'm Sam I'm driven by my colleagues ed
Chico ray and bill on the end there and
we have a really special guest with us
for this segment me a lot of Sun has
joined us to talk to us a little bit
about Legend of Zelda graphical wild now
earlier on today Amazon stop by i was
talking to us about the different ways
this game kind of steps away from what
people might think about it the
traditional zelda conventions but we'd
love to talk about with union motifs on
is how we're actually getting back to
the group's on the original Legend of
Zelda game
told us man I know then it or not that
in a row announced that they took a
philosopher there's not what she didn't
see ya ni they dead the attack today you
know la da da da da mota mota tazuna
adventure gah its finality support ck
ceremony that Nancy de mas-suh get any
motive a good one so you know we talked
about we mentioned the conventions of
Zelda but really endless series progress
there is a lot of more added features
like if you look at the Last Dragon
Sword and as we started doing that we
realized that the game is becoming more
and more sequential so we really wanted
to go back to was the original spirit
itself which resides in freedom
so we're starting to segment off for
those of you who may be
the morning segment you'll see a little
bit of the beginning of the game again
we're doing that for a very specific
purpose but one of the things that we
saw early this morning at the beginning
was that once again the game starts by
link waking up and I was curious why
make always wakes up to begin again yeah
monotony I know
but made then company
no salgo domini language
they'll mention that it might be a
little bit of Ricky but or this reason
we're doing that so I you know in the
original Zelda there was this just like
in the original de loja you start off
with really nothing much on yourself
madangir matsutake rato zika super mario
togo a sunday ma de text akwimos azonda
korea's episode on Sarah atanga you
steal our connect the monitor on fox
looks original cocoon there so that
isn't what I he became more than this
game or yahoo k mohan stay home Tony
vaporetto were courage even there
tonight as a possible areas show today k
mo doc goes in a preview of their cake
was that direction so you know when the
original Zelda came at the time people
were used to games like Mario when you
just play through the levels that cover
as they come up and we had feedback that
you know you you're tossed into this
field with a shield and sword and you
know weren't given any directions so
it's kind of confusing so we thought you
know what let's just take it all the way
we'll just remove the shield and the
sword as well and start from there where
the old man gives you the sword that's
what we did
sounds a little bit about your vision of
you know 30 years ago with all the
technology that's happened since in sort
of the concepts and that is that you've
been able to to see these teams develop
now over that time
consolas lahaa pony kono sekai solo
Monagas against a casino dirty know my
image registered at Ione cono cono
imagio m.ed stay a sunday class i din
TEI tarana yo mama so no I rasto Haruka
noqueira exam boga countenance great a
sono strata no no token in successive
une heure ET que route to savoy miss
Mercer then there's this image
demonstration that we started with you
kind of had to put that in a shin that
you were playing long but now you really
don't need that illustration this this
vast world ahead of you is you know it
surpasses the illustration and now you
can actually walk and do things in that
in this world that's come to life and I
think we actually have that reasonable
you see lead on the end of clip and
what's amazing to me
from the footbed
Twin Peaks that we have them right on
screen here now in that original
illustration here in the world of breath
of the wild how that captures the this
sense of excitement not only looking
over this cliff but also in here on the
edge of the plateau and you're just kind
of looking at all this space that
usually want to get to an explorer said
the NES game starts with an old man who
gives you a sword you start off in a
field and you walk into a cave to get
the sword in this game you start in the
cave and you walk out into a field so
it's almost like it's reversed
Nemoto son you mentioned the fact that
it was a very conscious choice to not
give the player a lot in the way of
instruction or tutorial idiot the
original Legend of Zelda a single reason
that you didn't give a lot of storing
information at the beginning and you
kind of dropped the player into this
world without telling them anything
about what's going on around them
ha ha
past all the times we've gotten to the
kind of tendency where we've there's a
lot of explanation by different indices
to tell you who you are and what your
role is that we went back to the origins
of Zelda and you know to discover kind
of who you are you don't know who you
are you don't know what you're supposed
to do and you're thrown into this world
and as your trap traveling and
interacting with nature trying to
survive this wilderness you learn who
you are and what your role is in this
big world
the NES Zelda game was every time you
walked into a new but you started the
game and you could just go off in any
direction which we see Chico doing here
heading off in a different direction
from where we I started from earlier in
the game but the other thing is that on
every screen there was movement every
time you entered a new screen there were
enemies on the screen and they were
milling about or shooting arrows or if
they were akhter rocks shooting rocks
and you have that same sense here but in
this case the movement is coming from
the natural world with the wild animals
like the boars you see the leaves kind
of floating through the air and you'll
notice things like squirrels and lizards
running around on the ground take it up
boku mo mata Ana's oh ok let's get off
together after she said no no doubt or
using
you see the Korean on cascara a no
further a heavy toll on a poor Henry
Nostromo sky in analogy voz de vida que
lo hace o todo na solaris kokoda need o
NHA co don't skate a mr. Pinkus a mohawk
aneema mo des kodomo Otomo's kumite
beaucoup she's damn easy Benghazi own
economies to know her universe today for
even act myself so this is an original
Zelda we were looking at obviously to
the screen that's what we were working
with and so to create some depth we did
things with the audio like having
different footsteps with different
surfaces to create that depth but now
everything is there not only visually
but orally zoo so it's really just your
it's almost like you're in the
wilderness and you're just experiencing
it for yourself
Chico you're pretty good yourself a
little please I'm pressure every missile
you know I come to see I stay far away
and [ __ ] with arrows to go didn't have
yeah if I did yeah
hematology
the extent of your involvement in the
wild and
no might smoke on a unicycle google it
is it to to producer to go on this way
no more I know it's a Himalayan
evaluated by a man alive new frozen I
collect efficiently let me go steady
dildo
funny ninky nonk oh god Sid Antonio ha
ha tony campana de nieve en dhoka dhoka
you can shoot oka so it when he tasted
their motto can you know under the game
burger don't worry mom he needs to dig
down amazon tobias santouka direct
attacks door Chikara program atoka
designer mean that it proves to be so
you know I think my position will end up
being executive producer on this title
as well but I have been in the past but
in past Zelda titles I took on a lot of
different roles as well you know even
though I was the executive producer I
did a lot of things that may be a
director would've but this time around I
my involvement is really focused on just
making sure that links movement is
natural and his interaction with that
environment in with nature is natural
and that it's it's all smooth experience
and really all the details I've left it
really up to mr. our new mother door mr.
fujibayashi and of course all the
designers and programmers they've you
know this is a really a collaborative
effort on everyone we have then I also
look after the financials
when she co was fighting the problem
that the ax there that your approach
would have been probably to shoot from a
distance if you tell us a little bit
more about how your approach as been as
you play this game
break the key before you jump into that
I don't have to point out how much this
reminds me of the original meet item in
the original NES zelda game Jodi gonna
MIDI gonna sit and eskimo sorry Brian oh
don't a Soviet amo de Latinos Sega stony
know I know thick tomo muchos cotton
easy Dickie Novakovic let's cut the
music company given Abu QIR quality so
sorry I took very good i know you don't
know tocar guitarra you know before this
string started we were kind of joking
around you know you can probably take on
again and with just just as he is in the
noon and you really can that's how much
freedom this game offers so you can use
all different kinds of weapons for other
kinds of enemies you can take their
weapons and use it against them so it
really does open up to any kind of
gameplay style you prefer it also opens
up a lot of different possibilities in
terms of how you want to approach things
like combat or puzzle-solving you know
in certainly the more recent 3d Zelda
games generally when you found yourself
faced with a puzzle there's one solution
whereas in this game even as we've been
playing in the tree house we found that
different people have very different
approaches in terms of how they want to
try to solve puzzles and I think Chico
is taking a slightly different approach
here to how she wants to deal with some
combat cuz i got suppose we did over
there thank you boy heal up good you see
here the wind is going towards the end
just use the fire to take it back to
where the enemy is role in the original
limb solve as well that's right this is
I think the first time in a while that
wink is able to use really fire as a
weapon in a lot of different ways and
the original ainias all the game you
could burn bushes and find things there
and I'm sure a lot of a lot of all of
you probably spent a lot of time burning
every motion the game especially bill
lost or anything that will seal of moms
too that's right so I think maybe what
we were going to do here is a switch to
a slightly different save data and we're
going to look at a slightly different
area of the plateau here
some pure silver miyamoto some is
removing lost another section of the
game it must be a really interesting
experience having been involved in this
series murder for this long I never this
many innovations have you found that
there are things that you wished you
could have had in the original Legend of
Zelda game you've been able to realize
over the course the series I know that
movie star on opanka should i dinna
Caputo Meekakitty oh yes I know gamba
remember programa token II program
eternity gah what she there was no mames
she's into city now so people nice wad
and you're still there Obama a no funnel
internal alveoli so resent aya is
holding the rondo modelica better
cognomen idea faucets to give you the
not give out all the models they could
view considers you know the programs and
designers instead of kind of trying to
make one sort one stack or one feature
available they tried to really recreate
nature ass is within the game and within
that step there's a lot of things that
came up and so there wasn't anything
that I specifically requested it all
came from the development the
programmers and the designers before
Papa George igloo she's in
guccione datos mono asyndeton deskah
know he got oh joy Oh Serena text a
photo de como kotero nobunaga t10 editor
momento y quedo atras y hasta la sono
dome walks on a yacht rock Arizona yoga
meet idan tonic Nikki avocado gonna soon
as we're trying to create this massive
world we did notice that ever during
that step we realized a lot of those
small my new details are being polished
as well so when you're playing the game
you you know there's all these details
and things that you just kind of notice
and i'll stumble upon for example like
you know when you look at pieces of rock
or stone some of them you gotta know
that you can't move and some of them
looks especially suspiciously movable
and you just kind of have this feeling i
just don't have anything near me phone
oh wait it's one I mean it definitely is
rich maybe nothing immersive experience
feel so good Bill Phillips bringing up
the chunk meat looking like the one from
the NES forgot
you know that was one of my first great
video gaming moments as a kid was going
into that cave scene grumble grumble and
bein like auto paint here's a puzzle
this is something to figure out and then
remembering because I had had the manual
memorized at that point because that was
all the literature we had back then I
was like I bet you he Scooby oh that's
there's meat then there's just like my
first little light ball going on I still
remember that moment very clearly ha oh
we gonna need to do like a day yeah I
didn't live to know yeah this was an
example here again you know and the
original NES zelda game sometimes there
were there were those conspicuous plot
spots were you you knew you could place
a bomb in that game sometimes you had to
tap the wall to see if the sound was
different but here in breadth of the
wild it's really interesting because
they've done such a very good job as
Miyamoto was pointing out of how the the
walls are designed in a way that they
give you a little bit of a hint that
maybe you can blow it up but there have
also been plenty of times where I've had
to experiment and see if it actually
can't happen that maybe I'll cut it open
mind about now just saying yeah yeah I
got an 80 snail who we do a little money
yeah it's kind of a feed gut feeling you
have when you look at it some here
sunbeam
it surprises you watch them to the dev
team play this game seeing the different
coaches they take or maybe them find the
game in ways the other members between
didn't expect I have Sarah photo place
you don't have played on this one point
the pin was about the darkest night or
not you put in just got another only
master hold it there modano holy
expletive nakanaide still amor acaba Moe
Bock's custom mods kappa gamma domani
mano de dou you do kids got a possible
Toxocara sojourn in eldo ok open slowly
yeah put yourself through a solid 000
don't on my solo me do something up
there you know so I actually haven't
beat the game so there's a lot that I'm
still discovering as well but you know
you think I'm just looking at some of
the development team play this you know
how they use different types of vehicles
and what weapons to use when they're
riding those in the book and then also
like the like the horse basically and
also you know when I there's if you're
really good at playing like you saw
earlier you can go into the slow-motion
effect so seeing that kind of high level
gameplay is really I learned a lot from
it kuroko no nobody to come on you still
there Coco tiny flaw no there nobody can
I kumanovo yo ho ho da namorada topa
topa takeno torre de naga demo show me
incorrect Nevada urahara hi tita
karakuri cara y una vaca toga I don't
know was not executed or
you don't have loot hola hi sorry so you
know even with climbing got to keep an
eye out for the stamina case and you
know you make sure that you have places
to rest when you are going up maybe you
could just go all the way around and go
from the back and lightweight and when
your may be attacking the enemy camp you
don't need to go from the entrance you
can go back around and attack the from
the from the backside so really there's
a lot that and as more and more features
get unlock there's a lot of more ways to
play the game and you know South puggles
Miyamoto's on one of the inspirations
that you had for The Legend of Zelda
came from your early days in the Boy
Scouts do you want to talk about that a
little bit much for a blessed day I know
Lucas tener dildo dildo dildo Guinea hey
kodomo no kuro boys con todo esta esa
cara oriente linguist olle ESO de haro a
lenovo so no mo know any supervision
idaho b.s cuando esta como la sombra
sono koe no doubt scooter laser Dawson
dodo void esta de 40 singando
tranquilizer a Yemeni decided like there
are two pokhara so come on in Russia so
you know when I was a callous and the
voice can I used to go hiking and
orienteering and there was a time when I
was climbing the mountain and it opened
cleared up into this beautiful lake and
I saw I've seen similar to that original
result they brought me back to that and
now looking at this of it it's even more
grander than it was
udoka reactionary Emma no Emma eat a
[ __ ] [ __ ] on des cadeaux cuchini mo
kio [ __ ] stay in a bikini its mother
Marie knows better than that you will
define optical cadeau de gallos Oregon
attansic on I Danny Donner volition got
AQ nahco no thanks yo c'mon you know and
when you're mounting climbing around you
have a destination but then something
strikes your interest so you kind of go
off the path hmm and then you know
there's a lot of interesting things out
ball but then just I know you start to
wonder wait what am I supposed to go
back am I going to be able to go back
but then that kind of feeling is just
recreated here and what's great about
this game is it was in the short period
of time you're able to really explore a
lot and there's a lot to explore
that's one of the things that I love
about the game is that just like the
original nes Zelda game it's it's very
easy to kind of wander off your path or
get lost in the world and find yourself
in an area where the enemies are way
beyond your skill level and then you've
got it aside if you want to try to fight
it out or if you want to try to turn
around and run back getting that good
yeah put it out of this on their own or
Iman haha which you're a victim ya know
each other who knows good man so she
goes are waving the family comic book
fans you move forward hood rat here oh
no for you bombo sooo cheap in this
sphere escharotomy corruption man you
would this very cut up you on there put
imam this will eat the case on their
competitors to the mall I know Pacifica
Dental Assisting pseudo god ok mandame
una ok so raven a two-man garage n go
home oh no no dilly alto so athlete
milkha bhaag okanagan I'd escrow yo soy
una foto you know like chico is stuck
there is it's cuz of the physics engine
at this game but then you know
see you can actually swing a fan and
propel yourself on a raft and these are
all kind of comic book-like effects but
taking that and putting applying that
into a physics engine creates this whole
new experience is very fun to watch of
course in the original NES zelda game
linked somehow had a raft that he
carried around with him but in this case
you'll have to find the rafting awake
and ready to cross so this man let's get
that on y'all what y'all want to know
you might find a rather than you realize
oh no I don't have a fans we have to go
back and grab it I'm looking to be
working on the skin and the members of
development team and it may be a budding
interest in hiking and maybe joining on
a trip with me figure 15 field trips up
to be amazing with everybody said Jess
tonight's game team building Choza yeah
I had to the hiking window god
hi pop is the game and they have to go
hunt them out
oh she goes on in this
when I use arrows to fight enemies I
always make sure to pick up all the
arrows that I use the boolean least in
paper due respect to the ones that I
guess I go back driver people taking us
in there take your days off so he
possibly can one more night they're
running out of arrows I let the enemy
shoot arrows at me and then go in grab
those and making my own Jonah food very
cautious player very economical Mesa
crazy but I'm somewhat of a reckless
player we've seen that she don't know
he goes chopping up some firewood here
I won't perhaps window
this is actually one of the other things
that I love about the game is that you
know certainly in the original eight
bits all the game the team did an
amazing job of using the limited color
palettes and the limited graphics at the
time to depict a very fully realized
world with a lot of different terrain
and we see that again here in breadth of
the wild but to to an exponential degree
and you see it just in the style of
trees that we've seen so far with the
forest down below to the fir trees up
here in the mountains it's really
impressive you even a student it's
indicated oh man [ __ ]
merci mon on TV tokyo production
if you go to the forest it really does
look like a horse you can get things I
found mushrooms from the forest
it goes without saying but
really is steam is so beautiful
english i'm against the current so check
girl okay so we're talking about the
fact that you've been really involved in
making sure that all the animations and
the movement feels really good I was
looking to people talk a little bit
about the temperature system and your
thoughts on that but if that's really
interesting as far as how it affects
linked as he's traveling for the world
englishes then you okay in no conscious
or something
no ever know a tony to talk Q&A so supa
dupa avatar at the condo game wanna come
on i phone a mono so heinous plot in the
studio more so that at least about some
meat over me not a mini beside that is a
gradual however the whole genome the
idea people you know so um this is
actually idea that came out just
entirely from the directors in the
development so as for example as you're
climbing a mountain to taller you go the
higher you go the colder it gets easily
have to prepare yourself by eating food
that gives you a cold resistance and
this game has a plethora of different
close that you can wear and so that
helps you prepare for any kind of my
environment that you're going towards
and then so there's a there's a
preparing yourself by having the right
clothes and there's also an element of
preparing yourself by eating the right
food I feel like this probably all
harkens back to your Boy Scout days
subway yet again by the boys got those
today you see with his hair yes
definitely yes would be some of the
admission with leaks cold and look at
oh and [ __ ] Randy yeah yeah I'm just
torturing him his clothes off yeah
minute so don't take your clothes off
here if he wasn't wearing boots in the
school
miyamoto was there anything else you
wanted to add in terms of the stories of
the development of the NES game or or
anything related to this game show that
no chi hudson NC General had a step to
the company of a single see their own
hands stuffed animals a soap opera oh
the snare I know you don't
usted que con evoke 10 condo near pomona
no Julianna sudo su koi de ahi no kodomo
slow day sorry oko yono piace quando tu
me haces a donde estamos de la mina
still there look so Mendoza Buddha yet
ewan KO kinda landscaper more ma dong PO
or sharing a ticket at all I know in
order that we know are no doopy us
administer the rupiah to becoming Skynet
again i doona you know he went i'm sorry
that i picked off haha that's me about
some of their mother people attend
Auriga in 10 marla therapy ok la
compania no buttons no he gave me not to
the power you know so as well you know
there's a lot of back and forth with the
dev team and there's a lot of items a
lot of ingredients that you can collect
and I'm kind of a lazy person so it's
kind of a pain to mess with all that and
so there's a little back and forth for
the development team but as it's
becoming more and more polished I
realized there's a lot of fun a lot of
joy to be had in there and there's a lot
is just really a lot you can do with all
of the options that you have this game
oh speaking of options check it out nice
moves Chico well thank you i'm being so
much for joining us and sharing some
stories about their development the
original game my house was kind of
bringing us back around the roots of
Zelda series it's really cool to see how
that you've been connecting enjoy taking
a walk if you haven't already know about
me bugatti opposing lifestyle school ms
Douglas this is you're good to go
everybody else
for joining us folks for watching please
a few minutes and come back to take you
into another of the shrines that you can
check out on the plateau so please stay
tuned the Quran